[Musique]
une opération escargot sur un grand axe
routier au Pays-Bas l'été dernier les
tracteurs provoquent des bouchons
monstres sur l'autoroute la colère des
agriculteurs s'étale c'est un plan
dévoilé au mois de juin qui a mis le feu
aux poudres le pays devra diminuer de
50%, ses rejets d'azote d'ici 2030 pour
y arriver le gouvernement a annoncé
qu'il faudrait réduire de près du tiers
le nombre d'animaux d'élevage dans un
pays aux profondes racines agricoles la
nouvelle crée une commotion tout au long
de l'été les manifestations se succèdent
[Musique]
et productrice laitière et travaille
aussi pour le plus grand syndicat
agricole des Pays-Bas
est conçu pour 320ches nous en avons 250
en ce moment mais si on en garde que 200
par exemple on a encore les coûts pour
tout le bâtiment les emprunts à la
banque il va falloir faire des calculs
on ne sait pas si ce sera possible
alors que le reste du monde parle de
diminuer ses émissions de carbone ici
l'urgence c'est aussi de réduire les
émissions azotées on vise entre autres
le protoxyde d'azote un gaz à effet de
serre 300 fois plus puissant que le CO2
il provient des excédents gré et de
fumier l'ammoniac est également ciblée
il est aussi généré par les déjections
animales
[Musique]
au Pays-Bas le secteur agricole est
responsable de plus de 60% des émissions
d'azote l'objectif du gouvernement et de
s'attaquer rapidement aux fermes les
plus polluantes Hades
le gouvernement nous dit qu'il faudra
éliminer de 500 à 600 fermes
l'État devra les acheter pour qu'elle ne
produisent plus
le gouvernement a débloqué près de 25
milliards d'euros pour la transition
pour les Pays-Bas c'est un changement de
cas radical après avoir souffert de la
fin pendant la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
les Néerlandais se sont dit plus jamais
et ils ont tenu parole ce pays minuscule
de 17 millions d'habitants est
aujourd'hui le deuxième exportateur
agricole en valeur au monde après les
États-Unis et le cheptel national
reflète cette réalité c'est la plus
forte densité d'animaux d'élevage de
l'Europe 4 millions de millions de parts
100 millions de poulet
la viande et le lait sont exportés mais
le fumier reste ici c'est ça le problème
notre secteur agricole est beaucoup trop
important nos chants n'ont pas la
capacité d'absorber tout ça
ce professeur retraitait de la plus
grande université agricole du pays
explique qu'on a trop tardé à agir
les premières politiques pour résoudre
le problème date des années 80 mais
elles ont été un échec
aujourd'hui les niveaux de pollution
azotées dépassent beaucoup les normes
européennes
pour Trinker dans les deux fils
voudraient reprendre la ferme la réalité
d'aujourd'hui est aux antipodes de ce
qu'elle a connu il y a quelques
décennies à peine
nous sommes passés de 140 à 250 vaches
en 30 ans la ferme pouvait grossir se
développer nos enfants eux doivent
penser à réduire réduire c'est très
différent
ici Catherine Mercier Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]